how to monitor machine learning in scale
or how to discover problems before your
customers do that was exactly your
question previously in the previous
presentation so we basically basically
we will cover the waste monitor and
machine learning in production and we
will show you a demo of how do we do it
in Salesforce
so first let's be let's begin with a
little explanation about our a automated
AI incest first Eleanor and has covered
it some aspect of it but I want to cover
it from different angle so probably you
are wondering why engine is here
so Einstein is actually the name of all
of our AI solutions in Salesforce so you
probably are familiar with the classical
approach to machine learning into AI you
have some problem you want to gather the
data related to this problem sometimes
it's a really difficult task and then
you want to try different models on your
data you want to evaluate it in order to
choose the right model but we're doing
it all automatically so we have turnkey
automated AI and we have thousands of
customers s eager and I mentioned in the
first presentation says first has over
100,000 of clients so think about how
much models were trading training in
production every customer is very
different as Eleanor mentioned says says
first has different customers from a
closed stores to Amazon to insurance
company to banks and cell providers and
so on so every customer is really
different and that's why we're trading
separate model for every customer
it's results in thousands of models in
production so I think some of you has
already understood why do we need
monitoring why it's so important to us
and I want to show you another example
of product in SS for the opportunity
scoring product so engine opportunity
scoring is a product to help sales reps
to do their work
imagine yourself calling to a cell
provider you want to buy their services
you want to ask about the price about
how to transfer to them so when the
sales reps is answered is answering your
call they open an object and fill all
your data all the data you're providing
into this object this object is called
opportunity so it's basically the sales
deal and that the sales rep is working
on so a sales rep is getting lots of
calls per day and lots of requests from
the web and so is dealing with hundreds
and sometimes even thousands of
opportunities simultaneously until
portunity scoring every sales rep was
prioritizing his work and he only using
his gut feel and now with opportunity
scoring will help helping the sales rep
to prioritize his work so similar to
lead scoring we're providing scores and
the sales reps can rank the
opportunities based on this course
together with scores were presenting the
explanation of this course from ask from
our experienced sales reps find it hard
to rely on this course there are no data
scientists and there they are not
familiar with computer science and so
they are they don't trust a generated
score by a machine so that's why we're
providing this explanation so basically
and how does it work
it's important for you to remember that
all the data we are using it's human
generated data so it can be very noisy
and very hard to train machine learning
model on it so and we're using the
opportunity object to train models and
we are using standard fields and also
every customer of Salesforce can can
create his own views and his own fields
so we are using customized data as well
our labels here are one for
opportunities that would the sales rep
managed to close and sell the product
and lost for the opportunities that the
sales rep couldn't close it and sell the
product
so we're training a model every 10 days
similar to its coin because we became to
the knowledge that 10 days is enough and
is necessary and because the customer
data is changing
think about your workplace how many
reorganization did you have how many
move movement between teams and so on so
let's the data is changing all the time
and that's why we have to train our
models frequently and in the end we are
providing this course and the reasons to
the customer so I think you have
understand the motivation we have
thousands of models running in
production in production all our data is
human generated and we have all the
overhead that Elinor explained before so
our motivation is we want an easy-to-use
tool to help us to discover global
issues in the product if for example
when we enter the code to production
that caused a degradation in lots of
models in production and the second
thing we want to be able to
actually research a specific modeling
production if it because of the customer
is approaching us or because we identify
his model is running and not as expected
and he doesn't have a good quality model
so want to research it so we need an
easy-to-use tool scalable tool a tool
where all the metrics are represented in
one place
and one of the most important things
will need an alert system we need a
system that will alert us on every
degradation in the production so after
we covered the motivation I want to talk
about our approach to monitoring our
machine learning models in production so
we defined a term it's a healthy model
term and we define it by three different
categories the first category is data
shape when we don't have a control about
the data that we are receiving from the
user from the customer so we need to
identify customers that we can train a
model for and that we can't do it so we
want to check if the customer meets our
expectations the second thing is random
Hills like every application in
production we want to see if there are
errors in production and monitor it the
third thing is quality health
here we are watering the quality of each
product model in production so let's
deep dive into each of the categories
and see examples of metrics you can use
so for data shape there are lots of ways
to measure these things one thing is
data size the other thing is biasing the
data if the classes are extremely
unbalanced the third thing is noise
you're very sparse data so in Salesforce
these challenges are translated to
these examples so sometimes sales reps
are not closing lost opportunities at
all there are only closed one
opportunities in order and further for
their managers to see the revenue but
they don't always have the motivation to
close lost opportunity so then we
received data with only one label and we
can train a model on this data detector
second thing as I described before all
our data is generated by humans
so sometimes sales rep don't feel all
the data then they need to fill in to
the opportunity object or they feel all
the data Red Rock retro actively only
when he and the subscript is closing the
deal he feel all the field and then we
don't have any history about the
opportunity so think about your
applications and how you can measure
data shape and the second thing is run
time health as I told you before we want
to to discover a receipt reduction but
the other things on top that the other
thing on top of that we have defined SLS
for products so this is this our example
first of all we want to ensure that all
the pipeline steps are running properly
the second thing we want to provide an
experience to the user where the scores
are changing due to changes he makes in
the opportunity object so that's why we
need to score the opportunities again of
many times per day and at least four
times per day according to our SLA the
third thing is model aging as I
described there are lots of changes in
the opportunities or in the way the
organizations are working and that's why
we don't want the models to age another
thing I want to mention that if we have
our customers with bad data
we won't monitor their runtime health
and that's why we filter a lot of noise
from our monitoring system the third
category is quality health you have a
lot of ways to monitor the quality of
your models we have to monitor the
quality of two products that are running
together this course and the reasons for
the client it's two different products
that we ended he is getting so you need
to choose your metrics based on the on
the experience that you want your
customers to help
so I described before the scenario when
the sales rep is ranking the
opportunities and based on the scores so
we're basically dealing with ranking
problem that's why we chose a OPR as a
low metric because it is very good
metric foreign King but we we came and
it became clear to us that the sales
reps it's nice to prioritize the work
and all but when the sales reps is
coming and closing the deal and he is
closing the deal is one he is expecting
to see the score of eighty at least and
not a score low as 40 even if this the
highest score for his organization so
that's why we are using also briar score
for the reasons quality the most
important thing for us is to present and
the more variety and quality a quantity
of reasons so if the sales rep is think
the same reason over and over again he
will lose he will lose trust on the
system and if the syrup is seeing small
amount of reasons he was all he will
also lose trust on the system so that's
why both of these things are important
let's look at some code
examples first we're looking at the a
OPR call example we're using
scikit-learn
for calculating this metric we're
calculating the precision and graph for
each model and then we were calculating
the area on this under this graph the
second example is the breyer scored code
example it's important to for us to
divide between the one opportunities and
the lost opportunities when measuring
prior score because if the data is
unbalanced we will we can hide problems
if we're measuring all of the data
together so thank you I want to invite
namah to present your demo so after we
understand the main concept of the model
health system to monitoring AI in scale
let's deep dive into the demo and to see
how we can use Daltry category all shape
runtime health and quality health in
order to actually identify issue and
bugs before we will start I want to
emphasize all the data that present here
in the demo is simulated and not a real
customer data yet it represent the
customer data as close as possible so
let's take a look okay this is our main
page this is the dashboard and you can
see it's contained four different tabs
each tabs has its own functionality and
we are going to cover it during this
demo the main tab the model health stub
start with the summary this salmon give
us a status of our system regarding the
model health category we can see how
many issue we have for in each one of
the category and it helped us to focus
well the problem and where we need to
prioritize our work and it's easy to see
that we are experiencing a lot of
quality issue almost mode almost a
percent of our tenant of a customer have
some quality issue in their models so if
I will open this dashboard in the
morning I immediately start to
investigate it and let's do it together
now in order to understand what's
happening we can use the PI section it's
helped us to break down the issue itself
by the reasons for each one of the
categories so we want to focus on the
quality issues so let's increase the PI
for quality reasons and here we see
really clearly that the main problem in
our system right now is a happen due to
the STD the STDs the standard deviation
in this measurement represent the the
diversity of the scores that we give to
a customer it's really important for us
that a customer will get various of
score in order that you can actually use
it to prioritize his work because this
is what this product give him situation
well for example we give for a customer
scores between 50 to 60 is just not
informative enough and we considered it
as a bad quality of course that if you
use this this system you need to think
what is a bad quality for your product
and your demand okay so we know we have
a global system issue because we saw
that more than 20 percent have quality
issue and we know it's related to the
STD in order to understand what's
exactly happening we can continue to the
trending page turning table the second
one the give us also the summary and the
status of the three category in our
system but this time he give us a view
over time we can see the change from
last day and here we can see that the
that we have a huge increase use rise in
the number of issue with our quality so
you want to investigate it and before we
get inside STD matrix I want to explain
about this graph the over time graph
here you can see aggregate a measurement
for all the important quality and
time measurement that we defined to
other product opportunity Schoen and
after get over all the customer in our
system and this is the 20 percentile
measurement for those for all the tenant
for each matrix we have a threshold the
threshold is the value when the 20
percentiles
for all the tenants is closet we
immediately get notification to our
slack in order to on the notify us that
there is a global issue in the problem
in a survey in the system so each
metrics have different threshold some of
the metals we want to maximize some to
minimize this is why the threshold is up
or above the value but this is the main
concept here let's take a look at the
STD graph and see what's happening here
it's really clear that we are
experiencing new job from yesterday one
thing is to open a bag and go home but
if you are a little bit responsible I
guess you are not going to do it and the
most of the people I guess we I'm sorry
I forgot to tell you that yesterday it's
not just we have a job yesterday we had
the promotion and we have we think this
has happened you to promotion so most of
the people will do some hold back and go
to the old version of the of the code in
order to prevent this regression but
luckily for us we don't need to do this
for all the changes we added to put the
promotion and we can just continue and
use our dashboard and go back to the
model health tab and look at the table
that give us all the data regarding the
customers for all the customers in our
system here we filtering only on the
customer with the STD problem and we can
see that all of them and share the same
configuration a configuration in our
model is the HIPAA parameter the chosen
for the AI model the machine learning
model for this customer like
and I told you each customer will have
its own model and sometimes it can be
random forest ik here can be if the
boosting or something else and each one
of them have different configuration the
chosen automatically during our flow we
can see here that all of them are
showing you the same configuration and
it's quite clear that this is what's
happening to the problem so of course we
after we saw this thing we immediately
remove the configuration we don't need
to do to go back to the old version you
can just remove this configuration and
retrain in those model and most
importantly we check those configuration
of the search but sometimes bugs happen
we cannot prevent them to happen and
this to help us to discover this I did
with you it in five minutes without you
I would do it in two months immediately
I discover what's happening without a
half getting giving continuous damage to
my customer and without getting any
complain from customer that see only a
score between 50 or 60 so we couldn't do
it without this a dashboard but I want
to say to show you another example
this was example for how we use it to
discover a global issue in our system
but how we do it when we want to decide
to find a specific model issue because
every a customer have its own model even
imagine so we got notification like I
told you we have also notification for
specifically a model and we got
notification about three a customer that
that costs the threshold for the UPR
they have released to me a Opia I
immediately go to the dashboard but this
time because I know the tenant I did a
customer ID that having the issue I am
going to the breakdown by tenant tab
this tab gave me all the information
about the shape runtime a usage quality
everything that I can find in my system
on this on the specific specific
specific customer I filtering on my own
the customer that I got in the second
defecation
and I can see immediately that I
actually have a quality issue regarding
to the LPL I can see another two thing
the first one is the stocks called
histogram and the winner it you can see
here that the Skog histogram the
distribution of the score that this
specific customer will have is really
biased and balanced and everyone almost
all the sky I give him is close to zero
also you can see it correlated with the
win rate the really low win rate in our
system win rate is the ratio between the
closed opportunity that close s 1
dividing by all the closed opportunity
so we can see those two those two
metrics are really unbalanced and really
have weird and it's suspicious but we
can see something even more interesting
we can see that this customer have
almost 100 a 1000 filtered a opportunity
filtered opportunity is a feature we
have in our system that give the
customer the ability to use this pile
knowledge about the data and to filter
opportunity from influence the model I
will give you example for example you
have that and you know that some group
of the disappoint of the opportunity and
behave differently from the other
opportunity and you don't want this kind
of opportunity will influence about on
all the model so the customer can just
filter it without asking us by itself
and using his data is ideas knowledge to
improve the model and here we see that
the customer actually filter but he
filter so many opportunity like 30% from
all the closed opportunity it's a lot
and it's really not normal behavior so I
want to see what's happening yesterday
or a few days before because just today
God is not fit notification so I will
filter the dashboard to the day before
and now everything looked differently
the skull histogram in the winner it
become normal and all in their balance
and more importantly I really don't have
any filter opportunity so from this
thing I can see that the filter
filtering that the my customer added to
the dashboard to solve to his model is
actually affected both the quality else
because the a you PR and the Akshay
because the winner it become really
unbalanced you can see how the winner it
behave until the filtering and since the
filter so of course after this I
immediately notify my customer about the
issue with his filter link and I want
you to think about it this customer
probably in the in the US II before we
went to it to his home he added some
amazing fields that he thought to his AI
model until I wake up I already
discovered that this filtering is ruin
his model and not if I'm about it and I
did everything while I use a and allene
thousand of customer and found this
specific problem in this specific model
and I couldn't done it without this tool
and the automatic element or anything so
I hope we convince you that monitoring
AI is important and we hope you can
think how you can use the the model
heads to use in your product and thank
you
[Applause]